Clint this is a film that you considered
doing as I understand that four years
ago you ended up deciding not to at that
time you went on to make Sully and the
15:17 to Paris and the mule why was this
year feeling like the best time for you
to make this and what was it about this
story that most intrigued you well I
didn't I we had a little trouble putting
the deal together the first time of four
years ago and it sort of fell apart and
everybody went their separate ways with
another studio Fox and then it was going
to be at Fox Warner's and then it was
going to be this or that and finally the
whole thing collapse and then just all
of a sudden that kept haunting me this
story and the screenplay was was good
and I wanted to do it but and then
Disney bought Fox and then the Fox
bought somebody else
I mean Warner Brothers said it was all
of a sudden it fell back in my lap and
so it came together rather fast why do
you think it did continue to haunt you
for many years it just seemed like such
a stories of injustice are always
dramatic and this one seemed like such
injustice and such some of our favorite
institutions did did wrong I jumped to
conclusions and so there was whenever
you get that kind of conflict it makes
for a good drama Paul you were nine
years old when the Atlanta Olympics were
taking place do you do you have any
recollection of that time and this whole
story was it not something that factored
in it was it's a guy that you had
remembered and followed over the years I
really didn't know much about it for
that very reason the fact that I was so
young but also you know it's one of
those things that even if you heard his
name you just assumed
connotation you didn't really know what
the deal was unless you became very
investigatory on the matter
reading Billy Ray screenplay was very
illuminating and then when I went to
fact check stuff I was like oh my
goodness they really brought him in oh
my goodness they tried to it just seems
so offensive to how they treated him as
if he had no concept of the idea of how
they were trying to trick him and just
do these sly sort of tactics that were
just them as I put it I think really
offensive to someone else in law
enforcement what was the process for you
to get this role I so the story goes I
was I was in Thailand doing a movie with
my buddy Spike Lee and I got a call
saying clinics or wants you to be one of
the leads of his new film and I thought
well that doesn't sound right and and
then it got goofier when I found out he
just saw a picture of me Jeff Fenech lat
and Tim Moore and I believe
jessica.meyer printed out a photo of you
know me next to next to Richard Jewell's
face and the boss looked at it and had
an instinct and kind of was immediately
kind of at least self sold I think you
had to sell some other people I mean I
think he's still selling people on the
idea but I but the reality is such he's
brilliant and when he has an instinct he
goes for it and I'm very glad I was the
recipient of the did you want to see any
tape on this guy did you want to go back
and watch I just wanted to do his
wardrobe but you would see night on
young black Klansmen yeah yeah I had I
had seen him on I on Tonya Harding for
Harding yes Tonya Harding I saw that and
I saw having a couple of those films it
just he looked exactly like Richard
Jewell I mean like his twin brother and
so that was a good start and then you
saw then you think well like it couldn't
be that he really can act also and then
it turns out that he was he he exceeded
all expectations
absolutely
Kathy as we saw Bobby Jewell was a
consultant on the film she was she was
involved I assume you guys had numerous
conversations what did she want to
impart to you and what were her
priorities in talking to you she it was
my birthday she baked me a pound cake
and she told me the entire recipe for a
pound cake and we spent a few hours
talking and still very emotional about
it and I remember her I said Bobby I
just I don't want to fail you you know I
want it and she's teeny weeny and she
just beat me and I thought well okay
I'll do my best and but truthfully the
more I learned about her relationship
with her son and and there's a book
called a suspect that's out by Kent
Alexander and and Kevin sulwon Kent was
a US Attorney at the time there and
Kevin was a Wall Street Journal and
they've been researching all of this and
they sent me a chapter about about Bobby
and and I learned that he was her only
child her only son that she'd had a
couple of miscarriages and so that was a
real a real clue to their tight
relationship and and also there they
were very active in their church and so
I just I learned a lot about their
background and and what kind of kid he
was and then you know he was he wanted
to help people from the very beginning
he was nine years old he run round
church making sure everybody had their
programs and you know we talked a lot
about his death mobile and yeah his
vehicle was insane he just had every
possible contingency plan in his cop car
so you know everything from you know a
black light to a slingshot to I mean a
hundred and thirty pound battering it
look more like Dennis the Menace's you
know a little wagon that probably than a
grown up vehicle but ya know they were
they're both such characters I mean that
I think that is fun to play them
he had beanie babies oh that yeah I'll
tell a really really quick story I'll
abbreviate um Richard Richard had such a
big heart it's ridiculous he had beanie
babies and little little teddy bears and
stuff that he would stuff into his glove
compartment so that if he were to show
up on the scene of a traffic incident or
or or worse involving a child he wanted
something there to distract the the kid
or make them feel better and you know
they don't teach that in the academy
that's just Richard Jewell I just want
to add one more thing I know you're
going to talk to Sam maybe I have to be
on top but there's one anecdote that
really you know slammed me when we were
actually coming back from our tour in
New York and everything was that one of
the stories that that they wrote about
Richard a guy who was very well known
sports a writer named Dave kindred
compared Richard to Wayne Williams the
serial killer in Atlanta this was during
the first week and he walked it back in
the Atlantic a while back you know
awhile later but just gives you an idea
of the kind of awful things that were
happening to him Sam are yes Kathy our
introduction to Watson Bryant in the
film the first few minutes of the film
is so memorable
to say the least what was your reaction
when you were reading Billy Ray's script
for the first time in reading those
first couple of pages it was I was just
blown away by the script it was a great
script and and and Watson when I met the
real well I talked him on the phone and
then I got off the plane in Atlanta I
hit the ground running and went straight
to his office and interviewed him and
Nadia and had him tape recording my
lines and and I thought I'd be there for
two or three hours and I was there for
seven hours and he was like I would say
that and no that's not how it happened
you know and I said well we're taking a
little poetic license but give me give
me whatever ad-libs you got you know and
he would throw in some ad-libs and and
then he but he really he is that guy I
mean that's he's this he's this
he's this real he's out of a Tennessee
Williams play you know and he has this
thing with authority
Billy Ray told me a story that he was
driving with him to get to dinner when
he went to go to dinner when he first
met him and he got pulled over by a cop
for his taillight or something and he
got in an argument with the cop you know
and said you're abusing your authority
and everything you know that's that's
the kind of guy Watson is Kathy from
your perspective the press conference
scene is just so powerful and
beautifully acted on on your part is
that a different yes is that a different
day for you as an actor on the set when
you have a scene that requires what that
scene requires or is in your mind is at
all just in a day's work was the
preparation at all different that
morning the preparation was long before
that you know I studied a lot the the
footage and we even added the
introduction that I saw that I thought
was so important that was so brilliant
that Watson said the hundred and
thirteenth pictum because she she was a
victim of all of this and so we added
that and couldn't use the whole speech
obviously but so I worked on that a lot
and and you know in those kinds of days
you have to kind of sit in the corner
and because we had to do the scene in
the kitchen after that you have to keep
the pot on the stove so to speak and
those days are difficult but it's an
honor to to be asked to do something
like that and I think one of the main
things that we wanted to do with this
film was make Bobby happy and and we
were Atlanta seeing her waltz up and
down that red carpet and beaming up at
Clint it was pretty great Kathy told me
that she had conferred with Bobby Jewell
and that she served me that speech that
she had was the exact wording of the
that Bobby had given her and so and I'm
fond of shooting rehearsals any way I
like
it's one of my idiosyncrasies and it
drives some people crazy but it's always
fun to see what happens when things
happen for the first time when this is
when it comes over your face the first
time and she that was her first take she
did that and and she and it was just
perfect the first time I was dumbfounded
and so that's kind of the luck we had
understand when you have people like
Cathy that who are soldiers and I can
fight now I can die happy
in Sam we've all heard these kind of
legendary stories of how fast clint as a
director works did it take any
adjustment for you and the other members
of the cast no we all just came in there
loaded for bear you know we came in
ready to go because we heard the stories
but actually there's no rushing on a on
the set with Clint it's actually a
really smooth you don't feel rushed at
all and it's kind of it was kind of it
was kind of seeing a Paul it's kind of
like shooting it felt like shooting an
Indy it felt it was incredibly actor
friendly because Clint is such a horse
whisperer with actors you know he's
really it's it's ironic that his image
of this sort of the John Wayne image
he's actually this very compassionate
sensitive actress director and he's
incredibly intuitive and sensitive with
actors you know Clint Eastwood
Walter Hauser Kathy Bates and Sam
Rockwell thank you so much and
congratulations